comienza una nueva era política en
alemania y después de 16 años con angela
merkel los alemanes tendrán que
acostumbrarse a hablar del canciller
hola soy un político que cuenta con una
amplia trayectoria tanto a nivel
regional o alcalde de hamburgo por
ejemplo como a nivel federal muy
recientemente como ministro de finanzas
y como el vicecanciller de angela merkel
olaf scholz llega a la cancillería en
gran parte porque es considerado un
político conocido una apuesta segura en
tiempos de crisis y de ahí que haya
análisis que aseguren que su gobierno
tendrá un alto grado de continuidad o
que por lo menos no habrá grandes
cambios radicales
scholz y sus socios de colección sin
embargo aseguran que quieren poner en
práctica una política de alto impacto en
temas como la lucha contra el cambio
climático la modernización del país o la
cohesión social hay mucha expectativa
aquí en alemania sobre la nueva era
política sobre la era post merkel pero
también hay muchas preguntas sobre lo
que realmente pueda realizar este nuevo
gobierno sobre el impacto que realmente
pueda tener con todos los objetivos así
se considera que por lo menos a corto y
mediano plazo el reto inmediato que
tienen el reto urgente que tiene será
lidiar con la cuarta ola de las
pandemias del pronaa virus que está
afectando a alemania de manera muy
dramática